on va retourner dans cette salle des
conférences du Sénat avec vous Quentin
vous êtes avec Franck Riester le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
Parlement oui bonjour sans crister
bonjour si nous accorder une interview
au micro de Public Sénat aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 24 heures du début de
l'examen au Sénat de la réforme des
retraites quel est votre état d'esprit
un état d'esprit volontariste d'avoir un
débat le plus riche possible au Sénat
contrairement à ce qui n'a pas été
possible à l'Assemblée nationale avec la
nupes qui a volé finalement le débat à
qu'attendait les Français nous
souhaitons comme les Français qui y a un
débat qu'on parle de cette réforme qui
puisse y avoir des discussions sur les
différents sujets de la réforme j'espère
que les choses vont se passer
différemment au Sénat j'espère notamment
que la gauche ne fera pas d'obstruction
j'ai entendu des mots des déclarations
un peu contradictoires nous verrons nous
jugerons sur pièce avec un mot d'Orne
l'écoute l'ouverture et la volonté de
débattre Franck Leicester on l'a dit
avec Hervé Marseille vous receviez avec
Olivier du socle la première ministre à
Matignon
vous deviez les chefs de fil de la
droite ici avec Gérard Larcher ce midi
quel était l'objet de cette rencontre va
te faire un point avec le président du
Sénat et puis les groupes de la majorité
en amont aussi de l'examen du texte ici
ou en tout cas de pouvoir échanger sur
les différents sujets qui sont des
sujets attendus par ces groupes pour
faire un point aussi de l'organisation
des travaux et ça a été de ce point de
vue là très utile très constructif on
l'a dit il y a trois mesures phares dans
les amendements qui ont été adoptés en
commission hier on parle notamment des
CDI pour les seniors de plus de 60 ans
la surcote pour les mers sur les
trimestres cotisés après 63 ans ou
encore le retour de l'index senior dans
l'entreprise de plus de 300 salariés sur
ces mesures phares que l'on a vu adopter
par la droite et le centre en commission
qu'est-ce que vous avez dit vous assez
représentants de la majorité sénatoriale
vous allez toper on a échangé mais on
n'a pas préempté le débat il y aura un
débat l'assemblée j'espère pour la part
première partie pour la deuxième partie
l'article 7 la fameuse article 7 sur le
report de l'âge à 64 ans et puis après
sur les autres articles aussi où seront
débattus ces questions là et le moment
venu le gouvernement s'exprimera mais
Franck riesta vous l'avez reconnu les
femmes sont perdantes dans cette réforme
est-ce que avec les amendements de la
majorité sénatoriale elles le seront
moins j'ai pas dit ça et bien évidemment
la question des femmes notamment des
maires de famille Israël sera regardée
et nous aurons évidemment comme sur les
autres sujets la volonté d'être ouvert
et constructif on a entendu une
conférence de presse de la gauche à 14h
les principaux les présidents chefs de
fil de la gauche au Sénat ils ont dit
que la majorité sénatoriale et la
majorité présidentielle maintenant
c'était la même chose vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse non pas du tout mais
on peut même si on est dans des
majorités différentes ou des familles
politiques différentes de se retrouver
sur des projets d'intérêt général et là
il s'agit d'un projet d'intérêt général
sauver le système de répartition de nos
retraites sauvenus l'avenir des
retraites de nos compatriotes alors
c'est difficile à expliquer c'est des
réformes qui sont difficiles peut-être
parfois pas populaire mais il faut le
faire parce que c'est l'intérêt général
pour sauver ce pilier de notre
solidarité qui est la solidarité
intergénérationnelle via ce régime de
retraite par répartition qui est menacé
par l'évolution de la démographie
c'est sur la stratégie de la gauche si
ils disent par exemple qu'ils vont
déposer d'émotions qu'ils veulent aller
à l'article 7 sur le décalage de la
mesure d'âge de 72 à 64 ans mais qui ne
veulent jamais aller au bout du texte
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de leur
stratégie je trouve que c'est si ça se
confirme la même stratégie donc d'une
certaine façon que ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale je trouve ça en
plus ouais bah écoutez on verra moi je
veux dire je vais pas faire le procès
d'intention je vois des déclarations
diverses attendant de voir ce qui est
certain c'est que je pense que ce débat
est nécessaire les Français le demandent
nous nous y sommes prêts et peut-être
que c'est un moyen pour eux de ne pas
dire aux Français ce que serait
l'alternative pour financer notre
système de retraite dans l'avenir pour
garantir l'avenir des retraites pour nos
compatriotes on voit que des
propositions ont été faites par certains
à la nupesse qui est d'augmenter
massivement les impôts les cotisations
nous le refusons et donc peut-être que
c'est avec ce type de pratique qu'on
essaie de cacher l'absence de projet
alternatif crédible oui que dire de DLR
qui pourrait vouloir aller plus loin sur
la suppression des régimes spéciaux
est-ce que c'est une ligne rouge pour
vous on était très clair sur les régimes
spéciaux et je crois qu'on va pas
changer d'avis ici au Sénat
[Musique]